hey everybody Sean McGuinness here
alongside shams George Johnny from
paradox and shams I'm very jealous of
you you've been messing around with one
of these new steam machines lately
that's correct we were lucky to receive
one of steam zone boxes they sent us
it's a sweet PC it's a quad-core with a
gtx 80 graphics card so we've been
messing around with it playing a bunch
of games most recently our own games
that actually run on the box without any
additional work from us because most of
our games run on Linux so I've got a eu4
here with the latest expansion well how
convenient that you guys have eu4 here
because a robust strategy game like this
one seems like a pretty good test case
for whether or not this steam controller
can handle you know your traditional PC
games exactly I think at least for us I
mean I've been playing around with it
for a bit and I've seen that some games
just have a more natural affinity to the
steam controller and one thing that's
really important to remember that this
controller although it looks like a
controller it and a gamepad it's not a
gamepad it's it's a replacement for the
keyboard and mouse and that's really
important to remember and some games
work really well on some work less well
and EU just happens to be one of those
games that work really well and the main
reason for that is I'll get into the
details basically but the heart of the
matter is that to play EU you basically
need a mouse and you actually don't need
to use the keyboard that much so I'll go
through the controls the left touchpad
is used as the WASD so it's very simple
to just scroll back and forth across the
map the right touchpad is used as a
touchpad
like you would found on a laptop it's
really simple in that way so and I've
mapped the the left and right click
buttons to the the triggers and the
scroll buttons that you would found find
on them on the mouse or just simply map
to the bumpers right so and I've have
the bottom buttons are mapped to
increase time and decrease time so and
finally we have pause and on pause and
that's basically what you need
to play you you really don't need you
don't actually need all of these as well
you can just do it with a mouse but for
steak and convenience I've mapped it
then it looks fairly easy when you go to
the you press a button you come to them
vine screen and you can customize your
controls and you can actually also pull
down community control schemes from the
Steam Network from the workshop actually
but we're using my own that I used so
I'm playing as Portugal and it's the
year of our Lord
14:51 plenty of July my goal for this
campaign is actually to conquer the new
world and we've just released an
expansion which allows us to randomize
the new world so you would find Cuba or
Florida about here but instead we have
something completely different we have
this massive super continent that looks
like no America that I live in shâm no
but one day perhaps God willing God
willing so what we essentially have is a
classic art strategy game here so what
we have is we have a we have our units
and we can drag and drop and select
these and as you can see it's it's very
easy to do so and you issue a command by
right-clicking and them they basically
move you we unpause the game and we
should see the little progress meter
here showing the troops moving otherwise
I just hover over different menu items
to get additional no additional
information just navigating the menu is
fairly fluid and and I'm not under any
kind of time pressure I can just take my
time read through stuff and that's
really why EU works really well because
I can just pause the game and play if I
had to click issue like bajillion
different commands at the same time say
I was playing if I was a high level
Grandmaster Starcraft 2 player this
would have been way more difficult but
right now it's fairly easy so we can
actually just move on to exploring the
new world I'll just take a fleet and
I'll actually issue a command for them
to keep on exploring so it seems like
the one thing that you do sacrifice with
this type of setup is those you know
those instant hotkey commands switching
between map mo
on the fly without having to jump into
the interface right I mean the trickiest
parts are essentially so far that I've
discovered it's coming to this menu here
I'm just grabbing one of these small
sliders I'm moving them across it
requires a bitter position and I think
that the the second big challenge for us
at least that paradox in the games we do
is that we have a lot of menus and a lot
of menu items just look at the sheer
number amount of data and I'm currently
sitting about a meter a meter or two
away from the TV and it works fairly
well right now but if I was sitting like
say three meters or four meters from the
TV these these menu items would be kind
of hard to read so it's a it's a it's a
challenge for us in order to go about
creating the UI rather than being
limited to the technology of the steam
box of the steam controller so from a
controller perspective it works really
well it's more of an u UI issue that we
have to work on but I mean paradox we're
always trying to bring our games through
new platforms on one of the platforms we
want to bring our games to or ammo is
mobile and from mobile we already know
that we have to update the UI so we're
trying to killing try to kill two birds
with one stone by just revamping the UI
a long term these kind of games and it's
still early days right I mean it wasn't
that long ago that I read saw on Twitter
that you had just received that steam
machine exactly I think we got this
machine just a day before Christmas so I
took it home over Christmas and I've
been playing it with for it've bits and
se eu works really well I played a few
hours I freely admit that it's not as
enjoyable as playing on a keyboard and
mouse but at the same time this allows
me to sit in the sofa back home in the
living room and play right so you win
some and you lose some so it's it's I
think it's a it's a it's a perfectly
fine substitution for the keyboard and
mouse if you're playing in a different
kind of setting when you're not by your
desk so it works really well and you can
kind of adjust the resolution so the
menu items will come bigger we're
playing at 7:20 right now so and that's
that's working quite fine so I'll put
you on the hot seat right now what is
the future hold for paradox and steam I
think that steam has always been a big
partner for us and we've wanted
10 biggest publishers on steam and steam
has really allowed us to be very
flexible in how we release games we
patch games all the time we add new
content to our games and that's really
this this team's biggest strength and I
we're really excited that they're
pushing Linux as much as they are
because that means that it's so much
easier for us to do Linux stuff during
2012 about 0.08 percent of our sales was
Linux almost nothing right but during
the last year we were actually rose to
one point 55% so we had a four thousand
percent increase of revenue when it came
to Linux sales and that's mainly because
steam is pushing Linux and that we've
followed in that push and released many
games for the Linux platform so Europian
themselves being one of those games so
for us and steam were quite happy being
in the same boat together and chugging
along and releasing new cool PC games
heading in a boat to a randomized new
world called Linux exactly awesome thank
you so much
you